we're live early we've been live 10
minutes early no
never there'll be nobody with us for a
couple of minutes but because everyone's
gonna be like they G live early what the
hell but we're just so over
excited um TQ Batman's been been waiting
in the chat for a while so he's probably
here he is um he's getting a question
when we go live in a little while
t b one of your questions has been
picked and the other questions by John
but anyway hello good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
sidet Trek and very very excited Jay and
Matt Gary's with us hey Gary haha's with
us hey oh my phone's messing up Tre gate
Tiki Batman who's got a question your
one of your questions is gonna be asked
byad right um t Gat is with us how you
doing
sir um right
so 18 months ago when you first started
messing Sid Trek did you think within 18
months you'd be talking to prad
right no no no no 18 month has it been
18 month BL it has hasn't it yeah been
pushing it yeah man I
started Sid trk just over two years ago
I think it was August two years ago so
two years like three months or something
and yeah yeah and I I started just to
talk about stuff because I was sick of
my other channel getting death threats
and I'm not even joking genuinely got a
couple um and you know and I thought
well let's talk instead of talking about
this stuff let's talk about something a
bit more chilled hey Jim how you
doing um and you know and I J here hi
Jim hey Jim hey Jim how you doing I
he's having lots of fun work friend Jim
we're very OV excited we need to calm
down I'm injecting alcohol into this
situation Dr so I'm genuinely quite
nervous I don't have any alcohol that
that why didn't I think of
that yeah so should we ever I'm drinking
lemonade let's pretend it's vodka vodka
should we tell the people what to expect
in little ising what we doing with the
companion
um I think they should
expect uh Brad Wright with a little bit
of more Brad Wright
um will'll be there as well but Brad
right Tod the RO was waiting and forgot
we started talking at
him well guys if anything like this is
right now do hit that like button hit
the like button we want this video to be
spread out anywhere and share the live
video that we're about to go on um it's
it does appear on the page as the
upcoming one so I know what I shouldn't
have done I've I've basically used the
same thumbnail three times and I think
it's confused people so it's a thumbnail
and it's got the warm-up show which is
now we're warming up like getting boom
boom boom and then we've got the actual
show which is going to be an hour and a
half Sid Trek has got 15 minutes
one-on-one with Mr Brad right where we
have uh well is it six questions eight
questions something that we're going to
throw at him an amount of questions yeah
an amount of questions um
partly we've got a couple of fan
questions to straight up and the other
ones are sort of like amalgamations of
fan questions so it's like guys asking
the same sort of thing so we've sort of
gone right okay this is the same sort of
so we ask we'll ask this question so
we've been completely um inspired by you
guys with the questions we've got um I
have the tiger I have the
tiger um brain pain how you doing sir
like like like like like thank you very
much um so we got 15 minutes then dial
gate we got 15 minutes and three fry
short I've got 50 minutes which is a a
YouTube channel I didn't know much about
until we we have
this um go and check them out it's one
of the
people I've been speaking to Athena on
Tik Tok she's really nice cool we need
to go on a video she's great all three
of them girls are great I've watched a
couple of her videos now they're
right who whose questions did you pick
right so John and TQ bat have got
questions krie um I we I did read your
questions and your your question
inspired one of our other questions so
we've sort of added them in to the
question we've got but we have had to
avoid talking too much there are certain
things we can't talk to bad about
because he doesn't want to um sort of
get too bogged down with like a lot of
the new Sci-Fi a lot of the questions
like are you involved in the new MGM
project and he isn't so we've avoided
those questions we don't need to ask it
we know he isn't so um so mother fig how
you doing sir so
right at 7 o'clock British standard time
we are going live with the companion
dial the gate gate world and three fry
short all four YouTube channels are
going to be streaming simultaneously it
is a celebration of
Stargate um and Brad Wright is joining
that conversation so we are going to
have 15 minutes with Brad and then dial
gate will I think we're first aren't we
um gate world will three fry short will
and then we've got a little bit of the
end just basically an hour and a half
show where we're gonna get to grill
grill Brad Wright um and ask him the
really important questions because yeah
all these questions are really really
two last questions are stupid but um we
were going to do a quiz with him but um
they still said it maybe maybe it's
probably for the best we don't because
because he's written he's done so much
work over the years he might not
remember any of these answers so we
decided not to but yeah we were told we
can't we can't answer ask certain
questions um we basically have to do it
properly and not like we normally do
yeah we're not we just ask questions
we've had to professional about this
it's like
weird it is very strange but I mean I
think the companion have been really
great about this and I think this is an
exciting thing I hope it's I hope it's
not a oneoff as well I hope it's
something do um you know maybe we do it
again when we do finally get the
freaking announcement um Amazon are
going on stage in like an hour at um at
the New York Comic-Con and you know
there's a slim possibility that they
might decide to announce something um if
any of you watching are watching that or
hear anything whil we're live please put
it in the comments yeah yeah yeah live
reaction would be amazing especially if
Brad's there as well well yeah that mean
that would be iconic would know if he's
there I I don't think we're going to get
um yeah I I don't think he it's going to
be like a full-on announcement but I
think there's a slim possibility we
might get a coming soon video that'll
have
a on the Chevon a Chevron or something
that's a possibility you know so like
a a preview that'll make us all go nuts
but I don't think they're going to stand
on stage and going we're doing a
Stargate movie I don't I don't think
they're I don't I don't think so either
but just anything if anything does
happen if if any of you hear anything
let us know we'll interrupt everyone
we'll interrupt Darren um
[Music]
yeah um I'm gonna I'll just answer that
question because I'll straight up answer
that question Brad R has a has an
interest in the companion so it it's
it's something it's a it's a thing that
he has set up with other people so he's
he actually has like a he owns a part of
the companion so when he does interviews
and things like this he does it as part
of the companion so he he he won't be
coming on Sid Trek himself basically um
but he's given us our time through the
companion and he's allowing us to
simultaneously cast it across um I'm
hoping this is something that we're
going to be able to do again um but at
the moment I'm just like um about that
we get to do it once if I'm honest I
mean I was I was surprised with the fact
that we're actually able to stream it on
here when when it all started coming
about oh we're going to work with a
companion I just assumed it was going to
be on the companions own platform which
I later found out the companions own
platform doesn't exist they use YouTube
which I found strange but
yeah yeah but I'm very happy we were
doing on here which is like the best
thing ever yeah yeah what would cause a
seven Chevrons locked an I think it
would have to be something they would
have to stand on stage and actually say
that this is something they're actually
announcing even if they do some sort of
sneaky sneak peek thing or something
where it's just a hint even then we're
sort of like well what are you doing
what are you doing you know like they
might just I I think that's more likely
um Dave's late I think I say we don't
let him into the main
show he says he says he's late he's
actually right on time we're
early he's actually still 30 seconds
early but thank you Dave um I saw that
that the D gate have got the um i h
you're going to be watching it here
though Dave right now I know everybody
go go watch this Live cast wherever the
hell you want but secretly I really want
you to
watch but um I hope you watch it through
S Trek but if you want to go obviously D
gate World B the gate and and three five
short are all going to be streaming it
live as well as well as the companion so
yeah no seriously as long as you're
watching it it really doesn't matter um
you could also bounce between all of
them if you wanted corporate t-shirts
yeah well we've got a got to represent
right we got to
represent boy I made this logo I'm going
to wear it any any moment I can yeah man
you you you love this you did a good job
with this logo soon as you sent a logo
it it reminded me it's very much of like
um
Metropolis sort of thing that's how what
makes me that's what me me reminds me of
Carrie you've got to stop doing this I'm
really I'm going to fall out with you in
a minute I'm gon to have to buy you a
t-shirt right please Jay keep these
questions to come into to Brad maybe let
Matt do some no Matt's not going to be
allowed to talk what I'm gonna do all
the J's gonna put his foot in it somehow
so I'm
gonna even I could annoy a
Canadian
what um I won't I will say something
that I think is
hilarious um and that won't be and um
and that will annoy BR it will be for us
for British people but all the American
Americans and Canadians are just be like
did he just insult
me little bit Americans don't get our
sense of humor today they just
don't we have had um one um very and I'm
not going to say names because that
would be mean but we did have one person
very upset with us another YouTube
channel very upset with us because I
made a comment that um somebody knew my
inner thigh leg thigh leg measurement
sort thing and I was taking the Mi that
this person had like Anyway won't go
into it all but they were very upset
with us um and now we had to explain it
to them why it wasn't because apparently
in America it's quite offensive and I'm
just like I don't get it but I mean I'm
certain there are things that we would
get exactly the same way that we would
find incredibly offensive that Americans
would do sometimes or you know any thing
it's culture isn't it Americans don't
get that sticking two fers up they don't
get it they don't understand why that's
an insult because it's Ain core
and um another story of that but that
come from no right so the French
obviously we fought against the French
and we had the long bowmen so we fought
them at Adin cor so when if the French
ever captured a longbow man and you know
an Archer they used to cut their fingers
off so they couldn't pull the string on
The Archers that's that's for that one
though isn't it that's the Americans no
that's that's where that come from
because you need your two fingers to
pull the string back so Ain call all the
English they going like this look we've
got our fingers that's where it come
from
and then obviously you got V for victory
and and and winon
Churchill yeah gu ask Carri I will
obviously put on all the and if you
please don't do this when we're talking
to
Brad going to once it's once it's cast
on here once it's all over and we've
done
our after show um I will edit out
everyone else and just put our bits on
this channel y okay cool I'm going to do
the same over the week I I'll do a best
of bits as well through the week and and
whever you and we'll do a couple little
articles based on what Brad said and
things will we'll have there will be
some
followup for weeks
yeah Sidra does not just bring you
rumors and um truth bombs about Stargate
Sid Trek and Star Trek and everything
else also bring you a little bit of
History bit of
culture who knew that when we were
talking about book plugs for several
hours
and that you would get a bit of
culture speaking of Star Trek I'm now on
season
three it's got got good now the B turned
up yet they turned up in season two oh
yeah they did the season three version
hasn't yet no I know they do because I
looked it up I was like when when did
they come back because I like them yeah
yeah Best of Both WS is the best episode
but um what do you we'll talk about Brad
and guys get into the get into the
comments as well what are you looking
forward to what are you hoping that we
get out of this conversation with
Brad
honestly it's it's just surreal to me
that it's even happening so I don't
think I have any sort of expectations
really um about what I'm GNA get out of
it other than the fact should that this
guy literally made one of my favorite
things in the world so I'm just I don't
know I'm just super
excited it is it is surreal like like
you said 18 months ago when I messaged
you going you haven't got a Discord
Community can I make one for you and
then you always messaged me I went I
can't do that do I don't want to do that
literally now now 18 months later I'm
talking to Brad Wright [__] hell like
how the hell does that happen I I work
in it I'm just a regular
dude I'm a I'm a not even a social I'm
like an assistant social worker I'm
nothing that's what I mean it's like
just regular people it's so weird like
you'd never think it's going to happen
I'm very happy I'm very happy yeah I
can't believe it I honestly I'm just
super excited and I just think it's
going to be and I'm not even just I'm
super excited for you guys that watch
our Channel because again you a lot of
you guys have have followed us from
really early on and where we started
dropping you know Stargate news way
before everybody else and you know we
started talking about this and we got
that Insight behind what was going on at
Amazon and then and now it's I I feel
like we're like we're almost giving some
of back you know because we like go
thank you so much for following us
here's bread
right come on and take a bow sir you
know I love that we're doing something
cool but I love it for for me and you as
well you know because a lot of work I
think thinking about it one of the
reasons I started I messaged you in the
first place was because you made a video
saying that someone had seen Brad Wright
in in the Amazon headquarters oh yeah I
messed up so you made that you made that
video um and
then I'll be honest before before all
that I was like I don't know whether
this guy's legit I don't I don't know
whether or not he's telling the truth or
blah blah blah I couldn't tell I
couldn't tell but then you made that
retraction video and I was like okay
he's he's got to be telling the truth he
seems all right so then I message you so
it's because of that because it involves
Brad wght the whole reason
why I initially messaged you and now
here we are going to talk to Brad R it's
like full circle
yeah it's it's weird it is that was
awful that was that was I actually got
told off by Brad right Brad right
actually messaged me said no I'm not and
I was just like first all I thought
that's [__] um and then I went back
to the um the source because if you
don't know the story if you weren't
watching back then
um any idea why Brad is doing this
because he loves
Stargate if he's not connected to
Newgate because he loves Stargate
Stargate celebration it's yeah which
celebrating the will talk about
potential Newgate a little bit we're
going up on the anniversary of the
Stargate movie and it's like 25 years
since Stargate sg1 start first started
so it's just a celebration of Stargate
with no attachment of this is Brad's
going to be involved in anything in the
future it's literally just this is
what's we're
celebrating oh dear I think I might have
bed up Med hi Med yeah Med is in um a
massive Stargate a massive Stargate fan
as well uh who really got kicked off the
um hashtag um bring back Stargate
campaign last year which was really
really successful did really well yeah
of all was was a big part of that and I
think he came up with it um so um what
was I gonna say can't remember got
distracted I got distracted by that I'm
started to feel quite unwell which just
before we go into Brad wght and I'm like
I think I might be sick not
great Jim Jim has just messaged me on
Whatsapp and he said where's my shout
out Jim when I saw your name I was like
work Jim and I was dead excited that was
your s a song I did Jim has a lot of fun
I said a song workmate Jim go back
Jim
um but yeah I mean for me I just think
you know um I don't I'm not I don't need
a weed just yet but I am going to go and
we've got five minutes we're going to
end this about 25 past I've got five
minutes I I'm going to go and drain the
lizard and I'm not drinking anything
else just in case um but we're only on
with Brad for like half an hour or so
then we'll be watching the other
channels um having their conversation
and I'll be able to TI off for a pee
then so it'll be fine um I I just I mean
I still can't quite quite get so it is
at 7 so it's in 50 minutes 50 minutes on
this channel don't go anywhere don't
don't wander off to gate world or
whatever stay here
um please if you're in our Discord just
go to dc. GG Sidetrack I will literally
post a link I mean I already have but
I'll post it literally as we go live as
well also we have a mailing list now and
we have 11 people who subscribed to that
got a personal email with their names
and like go and check this out so go
check like check our community page it's
there's a link somewhere there or just
decide .co.uk y exactly crack. co.uk um
we've got a couple of questions that are
really trying to so we want a couple
questions about what he thinks about
obviously the new project that we're 95%
certain is coming but also we've got a
couple of questions that we get a little
bit of insight into star you know when
he was at Stargate how he did it we got
a couple little cheeky questions one of
my questions literally starts with and
this is a bit of an Insider knowledge
Star Trek has shown that keeping Canon
straight is quite hard and that's how
the question starts so a little bit
cheeky little bit cheeky um the rest of
the
question um trevors in Irish gate give
us a shout out where you are guys let us
shout out where you are yeah like if
you're watching this like like like um I
love seeing some on the channel grow and
the contacts you've made from the start
of the channel yeah ter it's it's it's
been mad um you
know Jade should get a commode yes I'm
going to get a commode thank you thank
you Mel
um I work in the kinde of Industry where
I could get commod that's where all the
SRA money is going to
go hey mother go and have a coffee on me
then thank you very much sir can't buy
coffee all of these uh all of these
super chats is gonna buy your
commode yeah I could steal one from work
it'd be fine um but yeah I need to I
need like some sort of operation or
medicine or something stop me peeing Soo
much I'm getting old man I'm getting old
um stop drinking beer yeah well this is
Malibu and Coke so my wife drinking
Malibu and Coke's wrong with you this
whiskey in it or something maliboom C
nice no I can't stand it my M loves it I
would love to know J or disano do you
know I don't know how Brad did get the
job I know he was basically that him and
Robert Cooper and pitched for it at MGM
so I think it must have simply been that
after the movie they'd got the rights
for the TV show because obviously MGM
didn't initially own the Stargate
franchise it was um that oh I forgot the
name of the
company it'll come to me in a minute um
and but then I know it was I know Brad
and Rob pitched to MGM and that's that's
how they got it but I don't know where
the actual initial story I'm came from
so I have to think that um I am I was
watching apparently the Welsh doing well
actually when I came up the RGS were
starting to drag the Welsh back so
fingers crossed
um the Welsh will get yeah but the Welsh
absolutely smashed him in the first
first five minutes um but
yeah I I just I just can't
help you know
that I am gonna ask I'm gonna have to
ask Brad to say shut up Matt just for
fun just and then we're gon we're gonna
have
to then you're gonna have to make a
t-shirt you have to do
it with Brad right
going
I just I I yeah I just can't believe
this is we've got to this point I really
can't it's just I did this
channel you know out of fun really for
no reason yes please hit the Bell please
hit the like please the thing join us in
45 minutes it's G to be
amazing um oh God 45 minutes I'm so
nervous yeah I have I'm excited though
I'm excited um what have I missed Emily
everything you've missed everything oh
Brad Wright was here a minute ago and
you just you missed
it no you haven't you haven't missed
anything yet we start for minutes now
yeah we're just warming up we're just
getting ready we're just getting
basically we're here right the moment
because we're OV excited is basically
why we're here um and
then one of Harris's like fat dabs to to
Mellow Me
Down yeah uh I'm drinking Coke that's
just like I'm going to hop me up on
caffeine I am corn
Hol um I just oh
man yeah philippy can on come on thumbs
up thumbs up thumbs up if you haven't
thumbed up you're then you're a loser no
you're
not anyway so I we on 88 viewers that
means we can time travel now oh yeah
cool um
what what you think of some of the
highlights while we're talking about
we're celebrating starget but we're
celebrating Sidra as well a little bit I
think what are some of have you got any
highlights you think from the last 18
months you've been involved do you think
that was Bloody funny or that
was I put on the spot with that one
um I don't know it's it's all been good
um I think the Highlight for me is
seeing the channel grow the way it has
when I joined you just hit 10K yeah and
I remember having a conversation with
you I said optimistically let's go for
30k but realistically I think
20 and we've gone way past 20 so yeah I
we could hit if we could hit I think 30k
by the end of this year would be good
yeah um unless they announc Stargate in
which case it could go obviously it
could just go stupid but um I'm hoping
once say name Stargate we think because
I think there is a bit of fatigue people
are getting to a point now they're just
like for God's sake you
know how many more times I we we're
we're leaking all this info and some of
it's quite boring I find it I find it
quite interesting I find it quite
exciting but um but some people are like
again come
on um and it's and it's you know it
takes it takes a real fan to stick with
it over two years that we've been
leaking all this stuff and it's been a
roller coaster because it keeps changing
you know for six months you know we
thought or MGM thought they were going
to get to make Brad W Stargate they were
sure of it and Amazon were sort of
letting them believe that you know they
were going to get to do whatever they
wanted they they believed they were
going to sort of when Disney took over
20th Century Fox 20th Century Fox kept a
certain amount of um
autonomy and and MGM thought they were
or they're being allowed to believe I
don't know if they assumed it or they
were being allowed to believe it and by
Amazon but either way and they thought
they were going to get this level of
autonomy so they thought well we're
going to we'll do we'll announce Target
soon as sales come through Amazon all
rubber stamp it we crack on we're doing
the TV show and then the sale went
through and then they just went that's
happening and they instead of allowing
well yeah but instead of allowing MGM to
carry on they have absorbed MGM to the
point where MGM doesn't really exist
anymore it's not it doesn't really exist
Sue and Brad is involved
in some way oh no sorry no he's involved
in life oh God I mean you mean the the
new show I don't think he's going to
be I don't think he's going to be he has
got friends at MGM though there are
people at MGM that really really want
Brad wght involved the problem is the
people at Amazon are arguing whether
they even want to do
Stargate and there are people at Amazon
that don't think it's popular enough
then it's not worth doing um so we need
to those people are wrong well yeah 100%
but we need to we need to be here see
that Neil and thank you so much sir
really really appreciate it I monetized
this channel in six weeks which just
shows how popular it took me three years
to monetize my first channel three
years took me and then I monetized this
channel in six weeks which is just
astonishing just just amazed me um I
what the requirements are 4,000 hours of
watch time so 4,000 hours
consumed within six weeks that's insane
and what have we got now four
million oh no no no that that's no I'm
talking about hours I don't know how
many hours we're on collectively I can
find out actually that's an interesting
sta I can find out um
overview views watch hours we're on
10,000 for this
month um last 90 days I can't I can't go
to the full thing I can't go back all
the way oh I can't like
lifetime 314,000
hours watch
hours which is quite
good yeah we're not doing too badly 4.4
million views I I will try whether I
chicken out or
not um thank you don't for the love of
God send $70 I really will feel bad
please don't I will you you're getting a
t-shirt Carri when I get chance you need
to pick one
um I oh
manate
uh show us the diamond play button I
don't know what that means what Diamond
play button do you not know about
YouTuber Awards I know about the blue no
I don't care about things 100,000
subscribers you'll get a silver play
button at a million subscribers you'll
get a gold one the diamond play button
was
I think for 10 million or maybe 100
million for PewDiePie something like
that yeah we're not ever going to get
diamond play button
no um if I mean if we get if we get
100,000 subscribers I'm quitting my job
just live off this that's my wife and
I've got a strip on um on a live stream
which we don't want to do no because
that'll be the quickest 100K to zero
subscribers any
I'm going to strip to the theme music of
[Laughter]
[Music]
Stargate close the iris close the
iris of God don't open the
iris oh dear God H Co CL in
how to M oh D 50 million yeah he's got
100,000 subscri 150,000 subscribers I
believe um so C is a brilliant Channel
um yeah please
don't I think I think we can yeah we can
safely say I won't actually strip on
camera um but I I will be getting a
tattoo at 50k I'm getting a tattoo of um
Sidetrack Stargate on his ass yeah I'm
going to start getting my ass uh Open
the Eyes um and then yeah I just um I am
going to tattoo and I will film and I
will put it on the channel because I
mean come on uh mark my first channel
was um called um a brief history of
mystery I first started it right because
I was going to catalog Mysteries and
conspiracies in order like
chronologically so we started like
literally like like Mesopotamian period
and stuff it was like like 20,000 years
ago um and we were going to do it and
then we realized we couldn't it was
impossible it was a ridiculous thing to
do so we just talked about Mysteries and
conspiracies and stuff it's the
Channel's still up we used to just argue
about things it was it was fun Channel
um we did like Murder Mysteries and
stuff as well but but then we used to
tear them apart and break these like a
lot of these conspiracy theories down
into their and like Tred to find the
truth so what we ended up doing was
annoying the conspiracy theorists
because they thought we were all shills
and um that we because we said that're
they're that thing wasn't true but we
also annoyed like the people that would
like debunk these things because we
saying well some of it's true but some
of it isn't so we actually ended up
annoying both sides of like every
argument so we just ended up pissing
everyone off um fingers crossed for the
news we want yes Jim I I 100% agree with
you here I
think it do you know what to get
Stargate news
stuff um I've
had
has he just Frozen for everyone
else or was that
me me it was me it was me it's back
though okay um he was he said he was 95%
certain starget was going to get
announced this month and now he's maybe
30 because of the
actors cuz they were the studios were
sure they were going to um sign the deal
they sure they were going to go with the
writer's deal and go and it would be
roughly what the writers agreed that
would be the um you know the structure
the actors would go and the actors just
gone no we want more and we want this um
we want they're really pushing for this
profit share thing which then just not
going to get and they've actually just
gone no so the Studios have walked away
but Amazon are Furious Amazon and um
Sony apparently and maybe Apple are
Furious because um it was Disney hey
Warner Brothers and Netflix that pulled
the plug and said we're Walk we're going
we're walking out and I'm just like and
apparently everyone else is absolutely
Furious they're just like well just keep
talking for the love of God and the
Studio's g n no would not they're taking
the piss sort of thing and they walked
out um hello Mike how you doing sir
thank you so much for the contribution
really appreciate it we got 96 people
watching come on hit those likes hit
those likes and don't forget
to get ready for the show because we're
going to be going in 35 minutes gonna be
amazing right we probably have to come
off because we do have to go and join
the companion we have to join at half
six to sort of get everything ready
that's right isn't it it is half six
isn't it and then Brad's coming in at
about quarter two and then we've got to
have a little bit of a we're going to go
through the rundown and stuff um Kevin
thank you so much for the contribution
you guys are amazing thank you so much
hit that like K's got it right boom boom
boom boom um hit that like
button and then after the show come back
and we're gonna have a bit of a chat
about what just happened so we have set
it up for about quarter two but
basically as soon as we're off we'll go
live um thank you so much oh look Emily
Emily thinks I'm awesome
a I'm a bit
awesome I keep telling people I'm
awesome they don't believe
me
um but yeah you
ready no
yes neither am I I'm not I'm not ready
emotionally but I will be
yeah okay guys we're 100 people thank
you so much thank you so so much guys we
will see you in a few minutes with Brad
Wright thank you so much bye guys
bye oh I didn't hit the right button
sorry now I do